c'est pour moi franchement en terme de
notoriété on va me dire du n'importe
quoi mais celia brigitte bardot eluana
en terme de notoriété ou non mais ce que
tu es mené à la télé on t'a connu on
t'aime et on a connu les on a connu des
difficultés on s'est attachés aux
connaisseurs de ta fille de ta mère on
t'a vu sortir de secretstory on a tous
vu c'est le film avec jim carrey tu vois
ce que je veux dire on s'est attaché à
toi c'est c voilà sa voix contre soit on
espère qu'il n'arrive rien et tu te
rends compte de sacs encore encore
aujourd'hui dans la rue tous les gens
arrêtent j'imagine pas mal de gens oui
qu'est ce qu'ils disent oui avec toi on
t'adore ou on t'aime à ce qu'on pouvait
faire une photo un bisous et câlins
c'est pas vrai alors est-ce que première
question mais c'est la plus simple était
heureuse aujourd'hui oui alors attention
aux questions de mon psy oui les amis
aussi sans réfléchir deux indices si tu
te mettes une note aujourd'hui tu dis
quoi
ce matin voilà la prod gta iii
non c'est bien c'est donc tu es quand
même heureuse et amoureuse non ça c'est
le drame de ta vigueur tiens voilà c'est
ce qui manque tu vois les trois points
mais pourquoi tu trouves pas l'amour
c'est peut-être lui qui ne trouve pas
est-ce que tu connais la phrase est les
pardons les pas méchante mais tu sais
quand on rencontre canton bon de la
rencontre la première personne on se dit
ça doit être un connard la deuxième
personne c'est pas lui c'est un connard
la troisième personne n'ait pas eu c'est
un connard peut-être qu est la dixième
personne on peut se dire que la mauvaise
personne c'est soit
pas du tout pas du tout non est ce
qu'est ce que t'es pas il ya un travail
à faire sur toi peut-être parce que tu
es jeune tu es jolie comment tu trouves
que d'expliquer que te trouves pas
l'amour
d'accord parce que je suis le mec
mais je suppose que
je vais dire mais comment ça
non non c'était une image de de psy pour
dire que parfois il faut se remettre en
question en question et il dira
peut-être qu'il ya quelque chose de moi
qui fais en sorte que l'aja j'attire des
mec de merde mais elle est tombée sur
malmö voilà c'était pas eu tous ne
connaissent pas jamais j'aurais dit ça
non jamais j'aurais très peur loi lohan
a quand même le sera pas permis je te
connais depuis vingt ans en franchement
on aurait pu sortir ensemble mais les
hommes que tu rencontres je les
rencontre dans quel contexte loana tu
les rencontres soirées ou parce qu'il ya
plein de façons de rencontrer des gens
aujourd'hui et les applications d es ce
que tu as essayé des choses un peu
nouvelle pourrait séduire l'amour
ouais bon train on fait des rencontres
tout le temps et à chaque fois je te
remets à chaque fois tu tombes sur des
âmes qui ne peut résister encore
vraiment je crois que ça a dû être en
2003 avec noah ware et c'est un cercle
mais met vraiment à 20 ans
mais tu seras y mais c'est qu'elle sera
rejetée j'allais jeunes et de ne
t'inquiètes je
finis toujours lui même est vraiment con
magie était heureuse et je la quittais
malheureusement pas un connard et depuis
ça a été la malédiction de quitter
l'homme avec evra de ma vie et rim et
toi vous êtes plus du tout ensemble on
n'a jamais aimé non
comme tu es très jeune à essayer oui
vous avez essayé c'est ça mon meilleur
pote sais rien il ya quinze ans il ya eu
jusqu'à 1 0 début on était un peu bourré
avec
[Rires]
jamie en soirée
non non pas en tant que français mais on
rigole alors j'étais là quelque chose
qu'on fait c'est quoi ces conneries
avec un ami quand on a besoin d'amour
s'est jamais assez
mais c'est quoi voilà comme tu es
ma chérie oui regardez bons amis frères
way s'occupe beaucoup aller et bien
comme une très très belle on va parce
que je l'aurais pas fait si tu étais pas
bien mais là comme tu es très très belle
va repasser ton portrait en 2003 voilà
corps et c'était en 2001 même quand tu
rentrais dans le loft voilà oui
loana 23 ans depuis cinq ans elle est
gogo dancer
je vous ai une certaine image rendront
chaque siège travail en bateau n'est
donc pas y être cette année sans stress
en fait je rentre en vertu des sondes
la vocation de loana ce n'était pas de
danser sur des podiums mais à 17 ans
lorsque sa mère est hospitalisée elle se
retrouve seule pour faire face au
quotidien
alors loana c'est vrai que quand tu sors
en plus alors tu gagnes on oublie que tu
gagnes avec christoph leitl les et marié
ses copines mais c'est toi qui gagnes
pression voilà tu gagnes et derrière
alors tout marche pour toi d'abord il ya
un single que j'adore qui donnait
[Applaudissements]
et
là
[Applaudissements]
mais non
il s'appelle niet tu racontes tout ton
histoire gros succès là aussi et puis
après celle à 7,26 peu compliqué et non
non ont crié j'ai eu et j'ai été
styliste aussi tâté styliste est
vraiment état marque de vêtements mais
pendant sept ans et on a été chez hazan
merveilleux 1 quand même mais c'est la
vie on arrêtera de monte monte monte
monte c'est le sait le paris rio d'où
ils décrochent qu'est-ce qu'il est temps
de jean paul gaultier ensuite justement
après le défilé on m'a proposé de faire
c'est cette année
à la halle aux vêtements et puis après
eh ben deux mauvaises rencontres vont
être en compte en oisans contre parce
que tu vois là parce que tu être agile
des mauvaises rencontres chanter ce à
paris je connais ces personnes aient
fait ça tout seul tu arrives dans ma
valise et mon chien
très pathétique mais c'est vrai en fait
tu monte avec une telle notoriété on est
amis en que 20 ans et a géré moi-même
mon entreprise a zappé louana
productions internationales mais j'étais
la comptable la secrétaire celle qui
faisait les photos celles qui valide les
photos en fait je faisais tous les corps
de métier tout le monde croyait quand on
était dix dans cette boîte j'étais une
culture regrette d'avoir fait le loft
pas du tout je dis jamais que tu as vu
aurait pu être différente peut-être non
non l'engueulade pas d'une machinerie
l'on veut à personne de renaud ma vie
elle aurait jamais été plus belle que si
je l'avais pas fait c'est joli ce que tu
dis est ce qu'elle est semé d'embûches
quand même ta vie mais les jolies comme
loft annoncé personnes que j'ai
rencontrées et des mauvais choix
peut-être que j'ai fait mais bon c'est
exact on en fait tous on en fait tous
des mauvais choix tu as quelques pas et
des mauvaises rencontres voilà le tout
c'est de rebondir et on oublie aussi un
taxi quand tu as connu tellement jeune
que tu es toujours jeune donc il ya
encore toute victoire oui la belle promo
cd + concert alors raconte moi un petit
peu ces cd tu chantes avec donc ton
fameux potes
[Musique]
oh
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
alors attention ne pas finir comme lui à
retrouver sur un chiotte dans sa salle
de bain voilà samedi pour la fin est un
peu compliqué je ferais tu parlais des
rires
hier il n'a jamais pu retrouver
subventionne qu'il ya une intention de
bâtir une économie
encore vivant mais tu sais quoi mais là
où je suis vieux c'est que on n'a rien
fait de mieux jauger coûter encore le
rate pas que j'écoutais
j'écoutais abat un vrai que
c'est fini marty c'est formidable
fatou j'écoute toutes ces vieilles
chansons la semana
exactement là que tout va être sur scène
tous les deux on est sur scène tous les
deux on a monté un spectacle bien sûr
moi je suis la première partie tu sais
en quoi toi à moi je fais comme je t'ai
à mes obsessions à libé obsession
d'accord la prochaine fois je vous
l'amènerai un peu plus techno un peu
plus sensuelle d'accord et lui après il
fait tout le concert de lui et ensuite
lui fait son compère bien sûr de la lys
à comines et j'interviens qu'elle dans
des spectacles de temps en temps je suis
à ses côtés et on va dire qu'elle a un
milieu de son spectacle qui fait à peu
près une heure une heure et demie on
chante love me tender ensemble je le
rejoins mais non et à la fin bien sûr il
chante la dernière mélodies et je suis à
ses côtés pour ambiancer les gens pour
que je termine dans la joie et la bonne
humeur c'est un peu comme johnny qui
chantait avec est un problème
j'ai un problème je ne crois bien aussi
et bonjour
les gars et moi et moi quand je faisais
des petits peut être mais elle met pas
en doute et je chantais comme ça les
mots les mots sont jamais les mêmes
c'est vrai que j'étais petit mais pas du
tout des marines à la la
ça que mes parents du doute et
finalement quand je mettais un débardeur
et j muté ouais tu veux pas faire johnny
bébé non je veux faire un autre papa ok
c'est pas grave des maisons dont une
neuve à toi le concert ça marche bien ça
c'est dans toute la france ça marche
très bien on était il ya deux jours au
goût au
lavandou au lavandou voilà on doit le
mois prochain mais à paris où l'on
attend
toujours dans un théâtre dansé ou avait
écouté oublié le nom d'accord y'a pas de
mal instagram est bon on retrouvera
théâtre c'est quelque part dans paris il
n'y a pas deux il ya pas de soucis
études tu vis au shakhtar vendu ton
appartement bien sierre avait eu des
soucis d'argent tu en avais parlé tu vis
aujourd'hui je vis ou oui alors je vis
un peu
aux nomades en quoi que nos matches on
en malade je vis un peu chez éric
presque quand on est ensemble c'est très
bien mais comme on fait les gars là et
bien je suis avec accor sommes partis
non j'étais les valises un peu partout
voilà et je suis chez maman parce qu'en
ce moment là en train de déménager en
urgence
donc je l'aide pour faire ses bagages vu
comme beau père est mort elle se
retrouve un peu seul l éloigner de de
beaucoup de personnes mais vite fait
comme disait mon psy d'accord le site
pour les dédicaces toutes les semaines
la première la première première raison
du bonheur c'est la nidification trou
vous habitez pose tes valises et tu n'as
pas de nid avec bec
à bec il faut que tu fasses annie là tu
n'as pas de nid tu dors chez l'un chez
l'autre et rit quand on est chez tout le
monde on est chez pearson bébé tu
comprends ça oui je le sais donc même un
petit studio 20 mètres carrés et
remettre car et rouge coin des mamans
sera à l'abri je veux m'occuper de moi
même eh ben c'est très mignon